what i'm going to do in this video is
make a visual argument as to why the
derivative with respect to x of cosine
of x
is equal to
negative sine of x and we're going to
base this argument based on a previous
proof we made that the derivative with
respect to x
of sine of x
is equal to
cosine of x
so we're going to assume this over here
i encourage you to watch that video
that's actually a fairly involved proof
that proves this but if we assume this
i'm going to make a visual argument that
this right over here is true that the
derivative with respect to x of cosine
of x is negative sine of x
so right over here we see sine of x in
red and we see cosine of x in blue and
we're assuming that this blue graph is
showing the derivative the slope of the
tangent line for any x value of the red
graph and we've got an intuition for
that in previous videos
now what i'm going to do next is i'm
going to shift both of these graphs to
the left by pi over 2.
shift it to the left
by pi over 2
and i'm also going to shift the blue
graph to the left
by
pi over 2.
and so what am i going to get
well the blue graph is going to look
like this one right over here and if it
was cosine of x up here we can now say
that this
is equal to y is equal to cosine
of x
plus
pi over 2. this is the blue graph cosine
of x shifted to the left by pi over 2.
and this is y is equal to
sine
of x plus pi over 2.
now the visual argument is all i did is
i shifted both of these graphs to the
left by pi over 2. so it should still be
the case that the derivative of the red
graph is the blue graph so we should
still be able to say that the derivative
with respect to x of the red graph
sine
of
x plus pi over 2
that that is equal to the blue graph
that that is equal to cosine of x plus
pi
over 2.
now what is sine of x plus pi over 2
well that's the same thing
as cosine of x you can see this red
graph is the same thing as cosine of x
we know that from our trig identities
and you could also see it intuitively or
graphically just by looking at these
graphs and what is cosine of x plus pi
over 2 well once again from our trig
identities we know that that is the
exact same thing as negative
sine of x
so there you have it the visual argument
just start with this knowledge shift
both of these graphs to the left by pi
over 2. it should still be true that the
derivative with respect to x of sine
of x plus pi over 2
is equal to
cosine
of x plus pi over 2 and this is the same
thing as saying what we have right over
here
so now we should feel pretty good we
proved this in a previous video and we
have a very strong visual argument for
this in this for the cosine of x in this
video